we've all had tough days at the office
but some actor is dedicated to giving it
their all took their work a few steps
too far though these
critically-acclaimed often award-winning
performances are a delight to watch the
experience of preparing for and
recovering from these roles did a number
on the actors involved and left a
lasting impression not always for the
positive here are several actors who
went the extra mile for the craft
isabelle adjani possession any horror
buff knows the subway scene and andre he
left skis 1981 possession to be one of
the most horrifying shocking moments of
body horror ever to grace the silver
screen and if you haven't seen the film
buckle up you're in for a treat isabelle
adjani won a césar Award for her
performance but the intense physical and
emotional demands of the role made for
an extremely difficult recuperation a
Johnny leader told a French magazine
that it took her years of therapy to get
on out of her system and that she would
never again attempt another role like it
Adrien Brody the pianist though Brody's
physical transformation for 2002 'he's
the pianist is obvious the actor has
also discussed the enormous mental and
emotional strain of portraying a
Holocaust survivor which earned him the
Academy Award for Best Actor in 2003 you
know my experiences of making this film
made me very aware of the sadness and
the dehumanization of people at times of
war to prepare for the role Brody gave
up his apartment sold his car
disconnected his phones and moved to
Europe but it was the emotional effect
of intense hunger during his extreme
crash diet that he found the most
surprising and difficult challenge to
deal with Brody told the BBC I've
experienced loss I've experienced
sadness of my life but I didn't know the
desperation that comes with hunger there
were moments when he wasn't sure he'd
get out of the experience with his
sanity intact saying it took a year and
a half to quote settle back into things
Colin Firth The King's Speech Colin
Firth plays the future king of England
George the sixth and the Oscar winning
the King's Speech and has to give a
number of speeches in addition to a
number of other royal duties the film
has a villain of sorts in the form of a
near debilitating stammer that ruins
nearly every speech George gives until
he hires a vocal coach Prince Abbot
magic Arthur George Firth himself also
worked closely with the voice coach and
watch recordings of George speaking to
better emulate both his vocal
shortcomings as well as his physical
mannerisms and nervous tics on
stammering Firth immersed himself so
deep
the role that he admitted in an
interview that he's still occasionally
lapsed into the stammer when speaking
casually even briefly stammering during
the interview itself it's worth noting
that this happened in May of 2011 a full
eight months after the film premiered in
September of the previous year judging
by how flawlessly he had done seated
every syllable in Kingsman the Secret
Service while taking down thugs with an
umbrella in 2014 it looks like birth has
since gotten over the stammer Hugh
Laurie house during the casting process
of house the producers famously
explained that they wanted a
quintessentially American actor to play
dr. house shortly before hiring British
actor Hugh Laurie Laurie apparently got
the role because as American accent on
his audition tape was so convincing
nobody realized he was British the
director of the pilot even pointed to
the tape and said see this is what I
want an American guy Laurie also really
went for it when it came to walking with
a limp to portray the cane using house
so much so the actors still walked with
a limp in 2015 after eight straight
years of pretending to have one onset
Laurie also reportedly attempted to ease
the load on his leg by occasionally
switching the leg with the limp
something he claims nobody ever noticed
or called him on during filming or in
the years since the show ended
apparently Laurie's acting is so good he
can make people overlook both his
Britishness and the fact he didn't
always limp with the same leg despite
that being a defining aspect of the
character Bob Hoskins Who Framed Roger
Rabbit one of late British actor Bob
Hoskins most famous roles was that of
alcoholic le gumshoe Eddie valent in the
film Who Framed Roger Rabbit potkins had
to spend several hours a day for eight
months talking to and acting alongside
cartoon characters who weren't really
there scotch on the rocks
and I'm a nice hoskins would later note
that he learned how to hallucinate that
Roger and the other characters were
actually there to cope with the
dissonance of constantly hearing their
voices but never seeing them while
filming when shooting finally ended
Hoskins found himself constantly talking
to himself and even hallucinating that
Roger was sitting in the same room for
months afterwards prompting his doctor
to advise him to take a much-needed
break from acting Heath Ledger The Dark
Knight Ledger's performance as the Joker
in the Dark Knight was so chilling that
it landed him an Oscar for Best
Supporting Actor tragically it was a
posthumous award as Ledger had died of
an accidental overdose in January 2008
does it depress you Commissioner to know
just how alone you really are in the
years that followed his premature death
rumors swirled that the preparation for
the dark role had contributed to
Ledger's demise before filming began
Leger put himself in a strict isolation
keeping a diary of disturbing images to
enter the realm of a psychopath he
sometimes only slept two hours a night
while filming according to a November
2007 interview with the New York Times
it was a mixture of painkillers
anti-anxiety drugs and sleeping pills it
ultimately caused Ledger's death just
two months later Charlie Hunnam American
TV and movies Charlie Hunnam has played
everything from a soccer hooligan to a
giant robot pilot and he's known for his
extraordinarily convincing American
accent making him one of a handful of
chameleon-like British actors able to
convincingly pass as American in his
various roles you rescued her you raised
her
you're not protecting her now you are
holding her back years of living in the
States however took their toll on hon
Tom's actual real life accent and when
he appeared on TV in 2013 a plug a movie
on Conan he spoke with a bizarre
amalgamation of various American
dialects that prompted confusion and
mockery especially in hunting's native
UK I went out just as he was rounding
the side of the house and he stopped and
I looked to them and I said so we got
business mother Hannam spoke about this
in 2017 when he admitted that his accent
or lack thereof had gotten so bad that
when he signed on this star in King
Arthur legend of the sword he had to
hire a dialect coach to relearn how to
speak with an English accent the first
time in my career my name was above the
title it's Charlie Hunnam boom King
Arthur I said here we go Janet Lee
psycho Academy award-winning actress
Janet Leigh is known mainly for one role
playing the character who gets stabbed
to death in a shower early on in Alfred
Hitchcock's Psycho the scene terrified
millions including Lee after filming
wrapped she never felt comfortable in a
shower again in interviews Lee noted
that she stopped taking showers after
watching the scene I still I still don't
take [ __ ] that's the truth on the rare
occasion she had to take a shower she
would only use it briefly while staring
directly at the door and she wouldn't
even draw the shower curtain James
Cromwell babe James Cromwell is the kind
of actor his appearance is so
distinctive most people know his face
but not his name
he scored one of his few leading film
roles in 1995's babe in which he was
upstaged by a talking pig but it all
worked out given that it was not only a
massive hit but it changed Cromwell's
life turning him from a guy who
occasionally flirted with vegetarianism
into a vegan Cromwell has called the
experience of making the film a turning
point in his life recalling in an
interview with Vice that he was
profoundly affected by seeing a small
piglet react to being put onto a patch
of grass he said quote when that little
pig was put down on that big pitch and
saw the blue sky and the green grass and
the see that pig just took off and said
I don't want any part of this I'm out
Cromwell has been an ardent supporter of
animal rights ever since
especially pigs which understandably now
have a small place in his heart thanks
to babe and its sequel babe to a pig in
the city I know that I'm aware of their
suffering and I know that I
an obligation to talk about their
suffering and to do something about
their suffering Christopher McDonald
happy gilmore Christopher McDonald isn't
exactly a household name but his
performance and happy gilmore is so
memorable that generations of film goers
can't look at a picture of his face
without blurting out hey its shooter
McGavin that's just one roll out of many
in a solid career but it looks like
McDonald doesn't mind being forever
associated with the hot-headed golf pro
macdonald told The AV Club he took the
role basically because he enjoyed
playing golf and won a tournament
shortly after being offered the script
he was hesitant at first saying he
wasn't eager to get back on a film set
after shooting two movies back to back
but being paid to play golf and hang out
with Adam Sandler seemed like a pretty
sweet deal
according to macdonald his golf game got
sick since he played for five hours a
day six days a week while filming and as
an added bonus now that he's synonymous
with shooter McGavin he basically gets
to play golf for free for the rest of
his life
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]